October is Breast Cancer Awareness Month
we all know that our next guest is
sharing her own Journey with this
disease Katie Couric is an award-winning
journalist with more than 40 years of
experience in September she shared the
news that she was diagnosed with stage
one breast cancer Kirk documented the
screening process and caught the moment
her doctor found something of concern
so in addition to getting a mammogram I
also get a breast ultrasound on
ultrasound what I saw was a mass and
that mass had irregular margins and I
looked at you and I looked at the person
who is Imaging us and I said I think we
really need to turn the camera off I I
want to speak frankly can I stop for a
second
Oh Katie Couric joins us now Katie take
us to that moment because it's one any
woman who's been through this this is
the worst process this is the worst
moment for the doctor to say wait we
need to talk about this so did you go
were you documenting it because you felt
something or because it was just a
regular you thought it was going to be a
regular screening and you just wanted to
take viewers inside yeah you know hi
Gail first of all you know I wanted I
wanted to remind people so millions of
women I think put off their mammograms
because of the pandemic and as a result
many breast cancers and other cancers
for that matter being diagnosed much
later when they're harder to treat so I
really went in to not only remind women
to get screened but I also wanted to
talk about dense breasts because in
addition to mammography I always get a
breast ultrasound so when she said turn
the camera off uh my producer was
videotaping it on on my iPhone I wanted
to say no let's keep rolling it's okay I
I'm I've been in this world for many
years I'm fine having you tell me
whatever you need to tell me but she
insisted that we turn it off and the
next day told me that I in fact had
staged an early breast cancer that she
thought could be treated but we needed
to come up with a plan
but Katie I hear you talking about it as
a as a TV person as a person producing
the uh you know this screening but as a
human being when your doctor you know
their tone of voice changes or facial
expression changes and they say turn the
camera off I mean my heart would my
stomach would have sunk to my knees how
are you dealing with it there
emotionally well you know I I think my
heart stopped but I you know
for some reason Tony I just felt like it
was probably going to be early
um I don't know why
um but it was scary and it was scary
waiting for the results of the biopsy
which he called me about the next day I
have had so much experience with cancer
and when my husband Jay was diagnosed
with colon cancer it was stage four it
was metastatic when my sister Emily two
years later was diagnosed with
pancreatic cancer it was stage four so I
was hopeful and optimistic that if it
was something that we caught it early
enough and that in fact was the case but
of course it's nerve-wracking but yeah
you know it was not my first rodeo and I
think I had enough background and
experience in cancer that I wasn't
totally freaked out to be honest with
you
Katie you mentioned how the pandemic
like many other men and women has caused
us to miss scheduled health checks
um have you always prioritized your
health and if so what is your advice
because there's people sitting at home
that they really don't think about it
they say I got time oh well yeah I could
I'll get around to it yeah well yeah
I've always been extremely Vigilant
about my health especially after my
husband died and I became a single mom
and my daughters were six and two I've
been Uber on top of it but for some
reason I think the pandemic sort of got
us off schedule and and messed with our
sense of time and I was at my
gynecologist and she said you're due for
a mammogram and I said are you kidding I
just had one and she said actually no
you're six months late so my breast
radiologist recommends a scheduling your
mammogram and when you leave the office
scheduling the one for next year so
you're on the book so even if you have
to change it you're not going to forget
about following through but really what
I wanted to to do by going public with
this was to help women understand that
if they're among the 45 percent of women
with desperate dense breasts
from 40 and up they need to a find out
because it's only indicated on a
mammogram and then they need to talk to
their doctor about follow-up screening
in my case I get a breast ultrasound I
know Gail does too but a lot of women
don't know this and 38 states require
doctors to inform patients that they
have dense breasts but they don't really
give them any information about what to
do with that so the FDA is actually
changing their policy guidelines and I
think by the end of the year all Health
Care Providers will be required to not
only inform their patients but tell them
what their options are and what they
should do to follow up because
unfortunately you even 3D mammograms
which are far superior to standard
mammograms aren't really always that
great at detecting tumors if you have
dense breasts my radiologist said it's
like finding a snowball against a
backdrop of a field of snow because it
all comes out white so a lot of women
almost have individuals
that's why Katie it's so important that
you're talking about it you're right I
too have dense breasts were a member of
a very big group and it's important that
we do the right thing I have them send
me reminder notices thank you Katie
Couric thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you reminder women thank
you a reminder women should start
getting regular mammography screening at
age 50. now the option to start at age
40. you're watching CBS mornings we'll
be right back